Ruby Gilman is a 15 year old girl and
her and her family are actually Krakens
who are living on land for Generations
Krakens have protected the Seas from the
evil mermaids
we are from Canada our family is kind of
living under cover we're living as
humans but actually we come from
somewhere very different there's a whole
world down there that I have never seen
I know what's best for you and what's
best is to always stay on land it's much
safer for us
my mom is a real estate agent Agatha
Gilman and I slay the competition my dad
is an antique collector hey there
welcome back to bottled up he's very
proficient in those little sailboats in
a bottle let's get cracking I have a
little brother the classic like annoying
little brother mom turn
who's this like super lovable goofy a
little dumb but in a very endearing way
and then there's Grandma Grandmama the
queen of the ocean grandma is a force to
be reckoned with I never thought in my
wildest imagination I'd be playing a
kraken do you have laser eyes
they do pack a wallop Ness is like this
little Loch Ness monster dog the
personality is giving dog but the face
is giving Loch Ness Monster
you tiny genius Ruby's a princess
warrior she ends up stepping into her
power and choosing to fight for her
loved ones this is the coolest thing
ever
[Music]